[Musique]
oui la parole au petit nice et lisa
malone dupuis cette semaine on a célébré
la fête des mères je me suis fait un
cadeau à moi-même dimanche j'ai été à
québec pour la marche du pain et des
forêts qui était un grand rassemblement
de mer avec mr offrons ma place au
travail ça a été vraiment
merveilleuse expérience non seulement je
suis allé avec des jeunes qui m'ont
inspiré qui n'ont à déclic et j'ai pu
échanger
ensuite on a marché on de femmes avec
des enfants c'était une très très belle
marche était festive c'était joyeux
malgré une fête que le sujet était très
difficile très lo j'y étais j'ai apporté
mon abord comme mère et femme autochtone
et ce qui m'a inspiré ma chronique de
cette semaine c'est une question d'une
journaliste m'a posé en lien justement
avec quelque chose d'une question
qu'elle a entendu elle dans la foule et
c'était à oui on va parler des
autochtones aujourd'hui c'est quoi le
lien avec les maires
et vous pouvez comprendre que moi j'ai
jusqu'à aux lèves le matin sport de ma
chronique de cette semaine
ce qui était vraiment différent c'est
sûr que ce n'est pas une manifestation
dans jeux autochtones mais moi ce que je
trouve des forces justement d'avoir une
prise de parole en tant que mère et
femme a pas deux comme c'est d'amener
des sujets sont pas d'actualité mais des
sujets du passé une expérience en tant
que maire qui est basée dans un passé
pas très lointain et de le partager avec
les maires du québec d'expliquer que ces
enjeux le ce sont des enjeux qui peuvent
nous coucher tous mais qui est
présentement on peut se baser sur une
expérience vécue par les personnes des
premières nations des personnes
autochtones des nations métiers dits
nation inuit et pendant mon discours
j'ai changé sur les couleurs que j'avais
apportées avec moi j'avais trois coups
comme scorff 1 orange pour les enfants
qu'on retrouve dans les pensées de ceux
qui sont pas revenus mais aussi pour
ceux qui sont en train de
revenir de survie de l'expérience qu'ils
ont eue dans les pensionnats ceux qui
n'auront plus jamais pas jamais pu être
des parents qui ont connu l'expérience
la chance de vivre cette expérience
parce que leur vie ont été complètement
et celles qui ont dû guérir leurs formes
de parentalité à cause de l'expérience
des pensions ensuite j'avais amené un
foulard mauve violet pour joyce et
shaone pour parler justement de
l'accessibilité à des soins de santé
d'une mère qui disparaît et qui laisse
des enfants derrière de ces injustices
mais qui font concours la relation entre
les mères et les enfants et de ne pas
pouvoir accéder ne pas avoir confiance
justement envers le système qui devrait
prendre soin de leurs enfants et un
autre des co comscore que j'avais amené
c'était que comscore rouge bien sûr pour
les femmes assassinées disparu mais pour
toutes les causes que les femmes ont
apporté les inquiétudes quelles sont les
raisons pour lesquelles on se mobilise
justement les mains où elle se met dans
la rue pour pouvoir enfin en tant que
justement ces injustices donc ses trois
fleurs la très colorée venait faire
contraste avec le noir qui était portée
pour la manifestation pour la marche
pour parler du deuil du deuil non
seulement des forêts mais la
biodiversité et mes fleurs étaient
attachés justement avec un morceau de
cuir fumée des caribous que j'avais
beaucoup de difficulté à trouver
en expliquant que je demande à perdre la
biodiversité ça vous déconnecte ça nous
fait perdre ce lien la forêt cette
relation millénaire et qui en tant que
maire on doit aussi prendre le rôle de
vouloir protéger la nature
la capacité qu nos enfants on va pouvoir
en vivre a continué d'être là pour des
milliers d'années et j'ai expliqué
toutes ces angelots ce sont des enjeux
autochtones mais se sont pas encore ce
qu'on était des autochtones que nous
avons nécessairement été mis dans les
réserves mis de côté comme les caribous
et qui ont été mis dans des ou comme un
cadet mis dans des enclos j'ai dit la
raison pour laquelle on a été mis dans
les réserves il y avait bien sûr du
racisme et puis qui là dedans les
racismes et systémique mais il y avait
aussi une fête qu'on était dans le
chemin on était dans le chemin de quoi
d'une économie qui était basée sur
l'exploitation du territoire donc
en expliquant ce c'est comme si j'avais
apporté des fois peut-être quelque chose
qui dans leur esprit n'aurait peut-être
pas de toucher les mères québécoises les
femmes qui étaient là mais j'ai dit
c'est une expérience qui peut être vécu
une expérience que je pense qu'on
voudrait pas souhaiter à quiconque donc
en amenant l'expérience j'ai dit c'est
un passé qui est récente n'a passé que
connecter aux gens avec qui vous vivez
et en faisant la guérison justement de
ces enjeux le de céder et fait justement
de ces problématiques là mais vous
permettez à mes enfants de pouvoir
côtoyer vos enfants en sécurité de
pouvoir penser à un avenir et de vous
rendre compte que peut-être un jour
c'est son gros enfants qui vont être
dans le chemin donc vous comprendrez
bien oui avec des enjeux autochtones
mais ces dix ans jules mais aussi des
enjeux de droits humains et s'était
connecté à la marche des mers et je
disais c'est fou aujourd'hui j'en parle
mais c'est de dire comment encore dans
l'esprit des gens d'une déconnexion
entre êtres autochtone et être canadien
québécois que c'est une réalité qui est
déconnecté qui est loin d'eux mais alors
que ça devrait du vécu comme une réelle
difficulté dans leur société dans leur
communauté et en étant présentes à la
marche mais je trouvais justement on
élargit c'est un peu l'idée de la
communauté d'idées la maternité et
c'était en le confiant à des marques je
me sentais le plus à l'aise et le plus
capable de voir les choses qui se
développe autour de l'amour des enfants
donc j'étais contente qu'ils me posent
qu'elle me pose cette question là parce
que je me suis dit bon au moins je me
suis pas déplacé pour rien il ya encore
beaucoup de besoins de travail a été
fait pour pouvoir se dire qu'on a un
avenir ensemble et qu'on va développer
des liens communautaires donc une bonne
question encore avoir des bonifications
pourquoi suis je faisais chronique
encore semaine après semaine la même
manière qu'on prend soin des enfants
semaine après semaine c'est par un mot
puis si je pense parce qu'il ya un
besoin qui est alors n'hésitez pas à
nous envoyer des questions il sait pas
partagé général et chroniques je
souhaitais une belle semaine et une
bonne fête des mères à toutes les mères
à celle qui assistent libres à celle qui
nous accompagnent et mère adoptive les
pères qui ont le rôle de mère les maires
qui doivent faire leur travail tout seul
toutes ces idées de prendre soin qui
plus large que uniquement celui d'être
une qui met au monde un enfant